vous êtes chaud pour jouer et ce soir je
vais jouer mais à fond avant moi avant
moi la forte demande avant moi le déluge
rebelles
kelly b to b
[Applaudissements]
les séries et chérie inscrivez-vous tout
de suite sur les réseaux sociaux tient
hashtag ni oui ni non
si vous voulez jouer et geof tout de
suite l'album de rink amusant attention
je l'offre si kelly gagner une minute on
se rappellera qu'il avait combes est
invaincu vous être autre c'est vrai que
vous êtes plus grande que quand vous
êtes debout c'est la savate que le siège
illégal
c'est pour ça il est légal bataille de
sièges c'est pour ça qu'elle attendait
attendait non non et non je suis bien
attention petit réglage aimé diriger ces
bons génies japon attention nous sommes
serais toi top c'est parti un poste un
petit point qu'il faut dire alors je
rappelle t il faut dire ni oui ni non
mais j'ai un rendez vous après comme
c'est parti ça va ça va vous sinon c'est
un essai technique ça va a besoin de toi
ça va ça va mieux
tiens et a perdu un petit pois ah bon ça
va ça va vous coûter détendu maintenant
toujours bon c'est la première fois que
tu joues c'est la première c'est sûr
c'est sûr jamais joué avec moi jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais l'alléger
d'entre eux n'est jamais arrivée du oui
ça mais on peut dire oui non
alors at elle dit mais concernant mettez
vous bien apprêtée vous bien arrêté
jeudi à rome
c'est rien tout le monde l'a fait
alors aux joues pas vous avez vous avez
rendez vous ce soir nous battre allez je
vais je veux bien le faire je vais faire
je vais bien c'est sûr aujourd'hui je
vais faire ce new deal pour l'instant le
dit ce n'est toujours pas gagné à stein
me oui ni non
allez on va se faire un petit j'en ai
déjà fait leur village j'ai envie de me
refaire je vais me faire à montier oled
la preuve qu est ce qu il a fait la
tournée des trucs auxquels on se calme
alors c'est parti
oui oui c'est comique sans tain au début
d'émission top départ ça regarde très
bien je suis content de te retrouver ça
fait plaisir
moi aussi on se connaît depuis longtemps
très longtemps on était sur des musiques
des peuples au télé ensemble de vieilles
émissions au terrain pour si jamais tu
n'as pas joué au théâtre jamais que
quelques chante aussi
ça m'est arrivé pas fêté deux titres je
crois exact 1 2 tu peux donner les
titres absolument fou saissac c sur des
titres à l'autre les détenteurs soit
mieux la très détendue et tu fais du
sport en tentant de près vous attaquez
n'ayant comme un musée non c'est vrai
alala parce que jouer on verra c'est
vrai je veux dire vous avez dit non
c'est vrai oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ne laissez rien et a dit à quel bonheur
[Applaudissements]
ne vient jamais rappelle aux soins non
mais je reviens isabelle aaa et sa
tension c'est mes vêtements
tout d'abord ben justement ce soit vos
vêtements attention ni oui ni non
toujours invaincu toujours jean pierre
descombes d'une émission non ici tu te
fous tu te fous de ma gueule de foudre
et le moteur si on met les contacts
c'est parti bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes févry on irait s'est pas
fermé mais tout ça c'est aux autres tu
peux mais pas du tout pas du tout
d'accord a dit vous avez dans taxi je
crois que j'ai vu c'est de l'emploi taxi
moto taxi avec à peine à vous n'avez pas
peur n'aie pas peur même si isabelle
nanty
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
plus tôt c'est l'album de l'unca il a
toujours été marié à stagner we did on
allait au face à ce que ce côté après je
vais le faire à l'aide ce cocktails et
sony c'est qui vous voulez jean michel
aulas lalana c'est magnifique on y va
top départ c'est parti mais bien
encaissé du top c'est parti ça va très
bien joué et cravate à juin beaucoup
d'élégance je pense à la classe avant
tout tous les jours une grande
différence
vous n'avez pas non mais c'est la
première fois maire fois le titre de
cette chanson c'est lille ou lyon
c'est maxime allées marines et jeanne
mas
[Rires]
et puis c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le petit lac et le fameux sujet oui
ce qui nous happe et alors là ça va ça
va chauffer ça va chauffer chauffer ne
saurait m mais on y va venir pour une
minute et oui maintenant une minute
chrono c'est parti ah bon soir bonsoir
ça va faire un gros sportif c'est vrai
que j'ai des notions sportives tennis en
particulier tenir je suis parfois le
poing ou d'une balle de tennis
quinze grammes c'est pas le dire et
ensuite tu es sûr c'est certain j'ai
déjà calculé qui peut faire un un coup
droit lasso et en contre comme entrer
très tôt pour ça dans la gueule ça rien
dit là pour l'instant rien du tout
serein c'est certain je veux ce soit en
tennis
aujourd'hui j'ai tous les jeux reprenant
le week-end le week-end que le week end
puisque beaucoup de musculation parce
que j'ai décidé d'aller vraiment je sais
ce qui leur revient
je trouve que j'ai pris corporellement
et puis un petit peu de vélo aussi je
crois un tout petit peu des bombes en
cours le vendredi
tout le monde me dit pas ce que veulent
ils alors c'est le jour du poisson le
vendredi
donc je fais du vélo le vendredi
que tu écoutes
[Applaudissements]
et comme ailleurs